And educators across the
country are raising the alarm
over a new technology
that is making it easier to cheat.
It's called Chat G p t.
It's a chat
bot that runs on artificial intelligence,
and it can do
pretty much any things
you tell it to do
from solving a complex
math problem
to writing essays on nearly any topic.
So Chat
T has basically exploded in popularity
in just a matter of weeks
since it was released,
and teachers are now saying
that it's not all that easy to catch.
And that includes our next guest.
Darren Hick is an assistant
professor
of philosophy at Furman University.
He is also an expert in plagiarism
and copyright law.
And he just wrote a lengthy post warning
that this new technology
is going to spark a flood of cheating.
So, Darren, you're concerned,
but you were actually one
who recently busted a student
for using this chat bot to write an essay
if you were able to catch it.
How hard could it really be
to figure out if it's
a bot or a real person?
Depends on the level of material
that we're talking about.
In my case,
it was an upper level philosophy class,
and GPT
doesn't have the sophistication
to deal with some some obscure topics.
But had it been an intro class,
you know,
writing an essay
to show that you understood
some basic fundamental issues
and theories, it would have been harder
And so that's one student how,
you know, if you're a teacher
or you're teaching a
maybe an intro college level course,
how can people even prove
that it was a bot that wrote the essay?
Yeah, that's the hard part.
I have,
you know,
the instincts
that I've built over the past
15 years of teaching
that says this paper wasn't
written by this student, and that's fine.
And in more traditional forms
of plagiarism, cheating off the Internet
copy pasting stuff,
I can go in to find additional
proof evidence that I can then
bring into a board hearing,
something like that.
In this case, there's nothing out there
that I can point to
and say, here is the material they took.
It's really a new form of an old problem
where students would pay somebody
or get somebody to write their paper
for them.
Say An essay
farmer friend has taken a course before.
This is like that.
Only it's instantaneous and free
and it's on the Internet.
And they can just do it
basically whenever they want.
The other crazy thing about this
is that this technology basically learns
the more people use it, the smarter
it gets, the more sophisticated it gets.
Is there any going back from this?
Is this going to
dramatically just change
the future of homework or really
any other kind of work
that requires humans
to write things or to communicate?
It's I mean, it's a game changer
and it's just the first of its kind.
And as you point out,
this thing is instant
and it's trained to learn.
So it's
trainers will be working on this thing
a month from now.
It's going to be smarter than it is
today.
And a year from now,
it's going to be so much smarter.
And those things that made it stand out
when it wrote an essay for an upper level
philosophy class
aren't going to stand out
as easily anymore.
I think there's really two things that
teachers need to think about strategies
for how they're going to make assignments
that aren't easily written with
or easily detected,
at least when it's turned in that way.
But I think the bigger issue
is going to be administrations
who have to figure out
how they're going to adjudicate
these kind of cases.
When I bring evidence to a board
or a disciplinary committee,
what evidence is enough?
What's the right sort of evidence
to be putting forward?
And this I mean, it's brand new.
We weren't ready for this.